because these days uh
are
all into modern monetary theory
okay modern monetary theory is
accounting
i want to summarize it bluntly it's
simply saying let's do the accounting
because what money is is a creature of
double entry bookkeeping okay what's
double-entry bookkeeping banks this was
invented back in the 1500's in italy uh
i've forgotten the particular merchant
who did it
based on some arabic ideas as well but
the thing is if you want to keep track
of your uh financial flows
then you divide
what you uh
all the financial claims on you you
divide into claims you have on somebody
else which are your assets claims
somebody else has on you which are your
liabilities and the gap between you two
the two is your equity so you record
every transaction twice on one row
okay so for example if you and i uh do a
financial transfer
you have a bank account i have a bank
account uh your bank account will go
down mine goes up okay and that's
the sum of the operation is zero okay
but on the other hand if i go to a bank
and borrow money then my account goes up
they put money in my deposit account the
bank's assets go up okay and they're
still the same some applies assets minus
liabilities minus equity equals zero now
that's simply saying money is a
accounting a creature of accounting it's
not a creature of a commodity so if you
think about how austrians think about
money and how gold bugs think about
money and bitcoin enthusiasts if they're
any left think about money uh what they
see is money as an object okay
and uh you you and i can both have more
gold if we're both willing to go to this
you know
a mine somewhere and dig a few holes and
get a few specks of gold out so there's
no competition or no interaction between
you and me if money is gold and i think
money should be an object a commodity
but money fundamentally is not a
commodity it's a it's a claim on
somebody else
that's money's essence so when you do it
you must use double entry bookkeeping to
do it and then when you do you find all
the answers that come out of thinking as
money as a commodity are wrong
so for example i've got elon on this one
so i want to get this with elon because
i saw him making a comment about this a
few weeks ago on twitter he said that
it's wrong for the government
effectively it seems wrong for the
government to always be in deficit
okay now when you look at it and say
well
how is money created
how does money come about when it's
not a commodity like gold which you dig
up out of the ground when it's actually
social relations between people that
create money
well money is the
fundamentally
the liabilities of the banking sector
when you if we make a transfer between
us
your deposit account goes down my
deposit account goes up
those are exchanges on the liability
side of the banking of the of the
banking sector
but if we have a transaction with a bank
uh then if the bank lends us money it's
as its loans go up its deposits go up
again that same balance so you've got to
look and say money therefore is
fundamentally the liabilities of the
banking sector so how do you create
create additional liabilities you must
have an operation which occurs both on
the liability side and the asset side of
the banking sector so if you and i make
a transaction no money is created
money is existing money is redistributed
but if you go to a bank and by taking a
bank loan then money is created by the
bank loan so the liabilities of the
banking sector rise the assets rise
they're balanced but more liabilities
means for the banking sector means more
money
okay so that's what that's how the
private banks create money and that's
what i first started working on when i
became a academic but well 35 years ago
the actual dynamics of private money
creation but the government has the same
sort of story if the government runs the
deficit
it spends more money
on the individuals
in the economy than it taxes them which
means
their bank accounts increase so a
government deficit creates money for the
private sector
okay so that's where money creation
occurs from the government so it's it's
that it puts money in people's it puts
more money into people's bank accounts
by spending by welfare payments than it
takes out by taxation
so that's creating new money and then on
the other side on the bank
the money turns up in the reserve
accounts of the banks which are
basically the private bank's bank
accounts at the central bank
so
rather than the asset of
private money creation being loans the
asset of government money creation is
reserves
okay
right money creation money creation it's
a good thing so you mentioned a bunch of
stuff like private money creation with
the liabilities and the banks and then
the how the government is doing the
reserves
blah blah
at the end of the day is there's a bunch
of printers that are printing money
uh what is money and then you also said
something interesting which is social
relations
between humans is what creates money
i think my mind was blown several times
over the past minute
um so it's difficult for me to
reconstruct the pieces of my mind back
together but um
basic question is money creation a good
thing or a bad thing money creation is a
good thing
because money creation is what allows
commerce to happen isn't there a
conservation of no there isn't i had
arguments with physicists over this and
it took me a long time to answer it they
thought the sum total of all money is
zero yeah okay uh it's the sum time
title of all assets and liabilities is
zero so if you imagine
your assets minus your liabilities as
your equity
and your asset is somebody else's
liability and your liability is somebody
else's asset when we're talking about
financial assets and this is another
mind-blowing thing that i've just
recently solved for myself
so the sum total of all financial assets
and liabilities is zero
okay wait i'm going to interrupt you
rudely
what are assets what are liabilities
assets are your claims on somebody else
so uh specific you mean
give me an example of an asset okay do
you have a mortgage for this house no
i'm renting you're renting there you go
well if you had a mortgage that would be
your your liability that would be my
liability okay the mortgage with the
bank's asset
right okay if you add the two together
you get zero okay so that's zero that's
zero the money is the liability side of
the banking sector
okay okay assets are the
the the the assets on the other side can
be either created by the banking sector
which is where you get bank loans or
created by the government where you get
reserves but money is the liabilities
money is if you think about protons and
anti-protons in that sense money is like
the anti-proton it's the negative the
liability but we
the
liability is the negative yeah how's
that money i thought money is the
positive what is the liability for the
banking sector is an asset for you and
me
and an asset includes
money yeah yeah okay if you have a bank
account like you got you'd have a bank
account and you'd have some cash okay
okay those are your assets
but the bank account is a liability the
banking sector
and the cash is the liability of the
federal reserve okay so what what's
money well money is
money money is the promise of a third
party that we both accept
to close our transaction and this is at
the bank that's the bank yeah this is
one of the most important works i've
ever read is work by a wonderful now
unfortunately deceased
tiny italian economist called augusto
graziani
and he's the most wonderful personality
augusto
i met him on a few occasions
is one of the few human beings who can
speak in perfectly formed paragraphs
okay
superbly eloquent and what he did was
write a paper called the the monetary
theory of production
and you can find it uh download it on
the web it's uh it's pretty much open
source now uh and what he said is what
distinguishes a monetary economy from a
barter economy
so i said in a
in a barter economy what we do is you
know i'll give you two of these for one
of those yeah okay bada just would
working at a relative price there are
two of us involved and there are two
commodities so with money
money is a triangular transaction okay
there is one commodity i want to buy
that can of drink off you uh two people
and the price that's worked out ends up
being in a transfer from the promises to
pay the bank that the buyer has to the
promises pay the bank that the seller
has
so if i we so what you have is a
monetary transaction in a capitalist
economy involves three agents the buyer
the seller and the bank so the bank owes
has to be part of it well the bank has
to be part of it
when i hand you the money you accept
that as uh you've now got rather than
it's the bank promising to pay me
something it's now the bank promising to
pay you something and we exchange the
promises of banks and that's
fundamentally money
so money
it's fundamentally a threesome and
everybody gets [ __ ] okay is that a
good way to put it no it leaves
you like oh now now i can use french in
this conversation that's good that's not
french that's um
that's a different language i'll explain
it to you one
you australians would never understand
you